since quietly debuting on CBS in 2007
the Big Bang Theory has gone on to
become the most popular sitcom on
television here's a look at some stories
and scandals behind the scenes of
America's favorite sitcom about science
nerds the big bang that's aired for a
decade plus is very different from the
pilot episode presented to CBS in 2006
while he's now depicted as largely
asexual and mystified by romance Jim
Parsons Sheldon was sexually active in
the pilot there was also no penny
instead the attractive neighbor role was
filled by a tough not very friendly
woman named Katey you make stupid
choices and then you blame everyone else
they're calling me stupid no I said you
make stupid choice I'm stupid well even
the looks were different Johnny Galecki
Leonard mostly wore suits instead of
t-shirts and hoodies there was one other
noticeable difference the theme song was
Thomas Dolby's 1983 hit she blinded me
with science
cBS past but asked creators Chuck Lorre
and Bill Prady to rework the show and
submit another pilot they revised it and
added in a new theme song from Barenaked
Ladies which made it to the network's
fall schedule in 2007 over the years the
show has mined a lot of comedy from
Bernadette's voice when she's just
talking to Howard or her friends she
speaks in a quiet mousy high-pitch way
but when she gets angry she switches to
loud moments of screaming rage
neither of those voices come naturally
to the actress behind Bernadette melissa
rauch in fact for regular off-screen
speaking voice is quite normal
Bernadette's voice is very similar to my
mother's except without the Jersey
accent
that means that when Bernadette would
imitate Howard's late mother who spoke
with the Jersey accent she was likely
doing a fully accurate impression of her
mom in 2014 contract renegotiations
between the cast and warner brothers
delayed production on the show
ultimately CBS renewed the sitcom for
three additional seasons in the show's
three leads Jim Parsons Johnny Galecki
and Kaley Cuoco each secured a salary of
$1,000,000 per episode
meanwhile the show's male supporting
actors who'd been with the show since
day one also had to renegotiate their
contracts Simon Helberg and Kunal Nayyar
bargained collectively and both wound up
with salaries of around $750,000 per
episode that leaves the other two major
long-term Big Bang Theory cast members
melissa rauch and Mayim Bialik they both
joined the show later on in its run and
up until the 2016-17 season both raked
in a relatively meager $200,000 per
episode however for the show's eleventh
and twelfth seasons the highest-paid
cast members agreed to a pay cut down to
$900,000 in episode each with the intent
that the extra money went to Roush and
Bialik making $450,000 in episode in the
early years of the Big Bang Theory
Johnny Galecki and Kaley Cuoco secretly
dated each other concurrent with their
characters budding romantic interest
it wasn't until 2010 well after the
couple amicably split that either said
anything publicly about their time
together
Coco told company magazines CBS watch
that she had dated Galecki for almost
two years it was such a huge part of my
life and nobody knew about it three
years later kolecki gave his side of the
story the CBS watch weird dear friends
still Kaylee's not just an ex she's a
part of my life I just don't like to
speak about it and not because I'm
trying to be enigmatic I just worry that
it will conflict with people's
acceptance of Leonard and Penny
co-creator Bill fraidy says he first
heard soft kitty Sheldon's special calm
down song sung at his daughter's
preschool assuming it was in the public
domain he added it to the show where
it's been used multiple times and on
scores of BIGBANG merchandise soft kitty
kitty little ball of fur wait let's sing
it as a round I'll start in December
2015 however the family of a New
Hampshire preschool teacher named Edith
Nuland sued CBS for copyright
infringement alleging they lifted lyrics
without permission from a song Newland
wrote in the 1930s called warm Kitty the
lyrics of Newland song are nearly
identical however in March 2017 a US
district judge dismissed the suit ruling
that Preity hadn't violated any
copyright laws because Newlands
descendants couldn't actually prove that
they had a copyright on warm kitty Mayim
Bialik joined the series as
neuroscientist Amy Fowler in season
three and very slowly became a love
interest for Sheldon and a hopelessly
devoted BFF to penny
The Big Bang Theory had been on TV for a
while by then but Bialik hadn't quite
managed to catch an episode Bialik went
in to audition for the show without even
realizing how successful the show was as
of 2016 she claims to have not seen any
big bang episodes produced before she
joined not to mention most of the ones
that she actually appears in every
episode of The Big Bang Theory ends with
a title card from Chuck Lorre he writes
a new one each time and while it only
appears on screen for a second or two he
uses it as a sounding board for his
thoughts in 2010 one such card reported
on Laurie's discovery of a TV show
from the Eastern European nation of
Belarus called the theorists the sitcom
was about four nerdy scientists who live
next door to a beautiful blonde waitress
the characters are named Sheldon Leo
håvard Raj and Natasha Laurie was
convinced that the theorist was majorly
cribbing from the Big Bang Theory
lawyers at Warner Brothers television
told Laurie there was little that could
be done because the production company
responsible for the theorists was owned
by the Belarusian government but the
show was eventually cancelled anyway in
2011 a photographer spotted a tiny
organism in the Brunswick River in the
Australian state of New South Wales the
photographer knew it was a jellyfish but
couldn't readily identify it so he sent
his photos to jellyfish expert dr. Lisa
and Gershwin after two years of research
Gershwin and her colleague taxonomist
Peter Davy confirmed that the 15
millimeter creature was a previously
undiscovered jellyfish as one of the
discoverers Gershwin got to help
species and she went with bazinga rekey
the first part of the name is an obvious
reference to Sheldon Cooper's
catchphrase cry of triumph
[Music]
I have an override switch in 2013
biologists from a university in Brazil
announced the discovery of a new B the
orchid beat it so closely resembles
another species of bee the U glossa
ignite uh that the researchers decided
to go ahead and give the orchid be its
own official scientific name of you
blossom bazinga
Sheldon most often uses bazinga as a
kind of gotcha when he tricks someone or
plays a prank on them where did you get
them bazinga I don't care biologists
thought the word was a perfect way to
describe such a tricky beat that makes
it when a few insects on earth to ever
be named after a sitcom catchphrase The
Big Bang Theory showrunner released a
statement in response on behalf of the
fictional honoree Sheldon would be
honored to know that you glossa bazinga
was inspired by him in fact after Mothra
and Griffin's bees are his third
favorite flying creatures Jim Parsons
occasionally sputtered utterance of
bazinga is a classic TV catchphrase that
ranks with the all-time great t-shirt
worthy TV expressions such as cowabunga
or no soup for you it's Sheldon's
preferred term of triumph for a well
executed prank on his scientist friends
the phrase and the proper time to say it
is a direct carryover from the Big Bang
Theory writers room staff writers Steven
Engel who wrote for the show in 2008 and
2009 loved to setup fun and innocuous
practical jokes to rib the other scribes
co-creator Bill Prady explained the
origins of the catchphrase at a 2013
PaleyFest event that was Stephens word
for gotcha and he would use it in the
writers room when the Big Bang Theory
was getting off the ground in the
mid-2000s former child superstar
Macaulay Culkin was in the midst of a
comeback PETA ended a long hiatus with
appearances in two indie films the
religious satire saved and the club kid
murder mystery party monster Big Bang
Theory producers wanted very much to be
in business with the former Richie Rich
and Kevin McCallister
Kokan guested on the Joe Rogan
experience podcast in 2018 and told
Rogen no I said like now because it was
kind of like the way that pitch was was
kind of just like all right these two
like astrophysicist nerds and then a
pretty girl Liz whipped them yikes look
you know in the dead
that was the pitch in Vulcan didn't
reveal which character he would have
played but he did add that he had to
reject producers overtures two more
times The Big Bang Theory just loves to
insert musical sequences now and then to
break up the setup wisecrack laughs
formula and whenever possible they let
the actors perform their own musical
stunts that works out because a number
of the cast members know their way
around an instrument in the 2013 episode
the romance residents Bernadette gets
quarantined which leads to Howard
leading the whole BIGBANG group and a
performance of a special song he wrote
for her the actual composers of the song
are Kate Micucci and Riki Lindhome of
the comedy musical duo Garfunkel and
Oates Helberg sang and accompanied
himself on keyboards and it only took
him one take to perform the song
perfectly to other BIGBANG actors learn
to play instruments no small feat just
for the show
Sheldon plays the theremin an electronic
instrument used to make those spooky
high-pitched noises in old science
fiction and horror movies so Jim Parsons
figured out how to operate one too it's
a little easier to learn than the harp
which Mayim Bialik took up when the
writers decided that her character
should play the heart just before CBS
started airing the twelfth season of the
Big Bang Theory
CBS announced that the upcoming batch of
episodes would be its last co-creator
and executive producer Chuck Lorre had
gathered the cast in his office in
August 2018 where star Jim Parsons
announced that he was leaving the show
at seasons in immediately after Laurie
told the cast that everyone would be
leaving at season's end because he'd
opted to in the series rather than do it
without Parsons
according to Deadline Parsons told
Laurie of his decision a few days before
that meeting and plenty of executives
secretly tried to get Parsons to change
his mind
the four-time Emmy winner may have even
turned down as much as 50 million
dollars to stay with the Big Bang Theory
for two more seasons